let's continue cataloging and evaluating
some of the different reactions from
right-wing figures to the invasion of
ukraine by russian president vladimir
putin over the last few hours and things
are changing so rapidly that it is hard
to say this is where things are right
now but at least over the last few hours
we have not learned of any further push
into ukraine so far vladimir putin has
recognized separatists in the donetsk
and luhansk regions as independent
and then sent troops in
to keep the peace on the basis that
these are now independent separatists
who want to be part of russia donald
trump on a
podcast interview we played last segment
thought that it was genius savvy and
smart donald trump also put out a
written statement about what is going on
in russia ukraine and as usual it is
riddled with the same contradictions and
confusions that we have seen from donald
trump for a long time i will read it to
you donald trump publishing this
yesterday quote if properly handled
there was absolutely no reason that the
current that the situation currently
happening in ukraine should have
happened at all i know vladimir putin
very well and he would have never done
during the trump administration what he
is doing now no way now
missing in that
that there's already a lot to analyze
there and i know that it's easy to just
see the things trump says and kind of
write them off as the rantings of a
lunatic and that that you would not be
wrong to do that but when he says
putin never would have done this during
the trump administration
what trump wants you to believe
is that putin was scared of trump and so
he never would have tried this during
the trump administration the problem
with that is twofold number one
trump and the rights whole attitude to
putin during the trump administration
was
we should be nice to putin not that we
should be tough with putin so trump's
idea that putin wouldn't have done this
during the trump administration because
trump's so tough goes directly counter
to the narrative they were giving us
which is trump is friendly and correct
to be friendly with vladimir putin
that's number one the second piece is
it's possible let's imagine that trump
is right
putin would never even have thought of
this during the trump administration
one possible reason why putin would not
have thought of would not think of doing
this during the trump administration
would be that he feels as though he
doesn't need to
because the world attitude to putin is
much more friendly thanks to trump and
one
foreign policy analysis one one section
of foreign policy analysis about why
putin is doing this now is well
with trump gone and biden here
the global community is more hostile to
russia when it comes to nato expansion
when it comes to whatever uh nordstrom
etc and so putin feels he needs to do
something so i'm not saying any one of
these analyses is the right one but
there are many reasons why trump could
be
in a literal sense correct that misstate
the reasons behind it okay let's
continue
back to the quote russia has become very
very rich during the biden
administration with oil prices doubling
and soon to be tripling and quadrupling
now trump is trying to
link
biden to gas prices going up and of
course gas prices uh oil prices rather
started going up during the trump
administration due to the resurgence and
demand uh as covid started to wane or at
least we thought it was starting to wane
and so that increase started under trump
and it simply continued under joe biden
presidents have very little that they
can do about gas prices and oil prices
there's a strategic petroleum reserve
we've talked about that but it is it is
not even fair to say that it is related
to biden uh but donald trump wants you
to think that it is
lastly the weak sanctions are
insignificant relative to taking over a
country and a massive piece of
strategically located land so here trump
is is acting tough now it has begun oil
prices are going higher and higher putin
is not only getting what he always
wanted but getting because of the oil
and gas surge richer and richer the us
was energy independent under the trump
administration we actually still are we
did that story monday and independence
we never had before oil prices would
have remained low now what a mess our
country is in so just about everything
trump is saying there is uh wrong uh lie
or deceptive and
it should be interpreted as such but the
biggest sort of
most obvious
hypocrisy from the right at this point
in time is they were always talking
about we shouldn't be super tough with
with the with russia democrats want us
to have a bad relationship they want to
be strict they want to sanction they
want to be tough and at the same time
now they're saying well
biden's not being tough enough and we
talked about the sanctions earlier uh i
do think early they were weak they are
getting tougher i also think you need to
leave something on the table in case
putin does push further into ukraine we
discussed that earlier but trump's
foreign policy analysis worth basically
what we paid for it
which is nothing
it is a brand new year maybe you have
goals around getting in better shape
maybe cutting back on sugar
that's why you should check out our long
time sponsor magic spoon magic spoon
tastes exactly like the delicious sweet
breakfast cereals you loved as a kid but
magic spoon has zero grams of sugar 14
grams of protein and only four net carbs
so it's perfect if you're doing low carb
or keto or if like me you just try to
limit your sugar intake you can build
your own variety pack with flavors like
cocoa fruity frosted peanut butter
cinnamon cookies and cream waffle maple
blueberry that's my favorite
magic spoon lets you enjoy a sweet
delicious snack without the guilt you
can stick to your goals and still treat
yourself and if you don't love magic
spoon as much as i do they'll give you
all of your money back no questions
asked magic spoon is giving my audience
five dollars off when you go to
magicspoon.com
pacman and use the promo code pacman